ladies and gentlemen thank you for
clicking on this video and welcome to my
year in review for 2022 and the problem
is I'm behind the trend so I made to
feel late though technically I'm doing
this right on time because I'm filming
this on the 31st so I am waiting till
the end of the year to make my list
knowing that the majority of the people
that watch my Channel watch it for the
music reviews I'm going to start with
albums after music I'm going to move on
to movies and then TV shows and video
games and for the Intrepid viewers that
want to stick around to the end I'll do
a little personal recap on some other
stuff but without further Ado let's
start with my favorite albums of the
year
so the way this is going to work is I'm
going to blaze through some honorable
mentions first in no specific order and
then I'm going to give you my top 15
starting at 15. so just to quickly run
through some of my honorable mentions
for the year these are albums that I did
really enjoy but didn't quite make the
cut we've got midnights from Taylor
Swift the forever story from jid
ugly season from perfume Genius no thank
you from Little Sims Renaissance from
Beyonce Tana talk 4 from Benny The
Butcher the family from brockhampton
Bronco by Orville Peck cry Sugar by
Hudson Mohawk and Moto mommy from
Rosalia so now we get into my top 15 and
these will be ranked but let's kick it
off with number 15 Burger King foot
lettuce I'm sorry I meant to say Capri
songs by FKA twigs I've been a fan of
twigs for a few years and this album was
quite a departure from her usual fare
it's a lot more energetic and I think it
might have been characterized as a
mixtape I don't really know what that
means to her but it's a great project
and there's a lot of fun times on there
number 14 is ethiops from Billy Woods
ethiops is a really dark and Dusty rap
project which is kind of par for the
course from Billy Woods if you're
familiar with his work if you're not uh
buckle up it's kind of a interesting
psychological trip but really cool album
Number 13 is going to be beatopia from
Biba doobie I love saying that name uh
she's great she's really kind of
bringing the spirit of like 90s grunge
Rock to pop music which is a mixture
that I wouldn't have expected to work as
well as it does but she's got a handle
on it number 12 is going to be sick from
Earl Sweatshirt I'm actually kind of
sick today so I can relate to this album
especially we all know Earl Sweatshirt
as an extremely introspective rapper and
this album is no exception it's very low
key compared to some of his other stuff
but honestly a lot of his stuff has been
low-key the last few years so again par
for the course for him too but I like
this one it's concise and there are
still some bangers even though it is as
chill as it is number 11 for me is going
to be big thief's dragon new warm
Mountain I Believe In You Big Thief is a
great band I love Adrian lenker and all
of her work this album is really
ambitious it's very long but there's a
lot of variety and a lot of emotions
covered on this one all in all I think I
describe it as a feel-good album which
there aren't too many of these days now
we find ourselves in the top 10 and
coming in at number 10 is going to be
her loss from Drake and 21 Savage as far
as Drake rap albums go this is one of
the best in recent memory there's a lot
of great stuff on here and even though
there's some that I would personally not
return to the songs that I do like are
great and I find myself replaying that
playlist of about eight tracks over and
over if you want to check that out I've
got it on Spotify and apple music not
really an album just my favorites from
the album I really like what was done on
here and I feel like I'm referring to
this all as the result of Drake because
21 Savage just feels like a guest but
that's okay he holds his own number nine
for me is going to be Alex G's God Save
The Animals honestly I don't really know
what to say about this album other than
I really enjoyed it pretty much front to
back Alex G is a great alt rocker guy
and the sounds and atmosphere all over
are very comforting at number eight is
once again Drake Drake made two albums
in my top ten this year I did not think
I'd ever say that in my life honestly
never mind it's sort of an exploration
into low-key house music from Drake and
for a lot of people that missed the mark
and I get that but for me I I really
enjoyed this one and I've got a whole
video explaining that if you want that
in more detail but yeah I'm astonished
personally to see Drake on my list not
once but twice in one year and yeah I
liked this album more because I think it
is more consistent and I love the
production Drake's vocals leave a bit to
be desired sometimes but you know what I
applaud what he did I applaud the risk
that he took coming in at number seven
is it's almost dry from Pusha T this
album came out pretty early in the year
so I think it was easy for people to
forget but the music itself doesn't
really let you forget it because it's
extremely well crafted great production
from Pharrell and he who must not be
named Kanye West and Pusha T just doing
what Pusha T does best there's a lot of
great stuff on this album it's very
tight very very concise and absolutely
packs a punch number six I've got the
elephant Man's Bones from Rock Marciano
and The Alchemist you know exactly what
kind of atmosphere Alchemist is bringing
with his production and rock Marciano on
those beats is perfect this is a pairing
that seems so natural that it's honestly
frustrating that they haven't made
albums like this before but yeah
elephant Man's Bones goes crazy and if
you're looking for something hypnotic go
here number five on my list is going to
be scissors SOS it's been five years
since we got control from scissors so
this was long awaited it's a pretty
bulky album at 23 tracks though the
runtime isn't that crazy and a lot of
the themes that she's exploring on here
are troubling and I hope she's playing a
character because she seems very hung up
on a lot of things in her past I hope
she's doing better but despite that
there are a lot of lyrical gems in here
the production is fantastic and her
voice is just unmatched in any genre I
will always maintain that she could just
sing items off a grocery list and I
would buy her albums and I did have the
pleasure of seeing her live or earlier
this year and that was crazy too big
fantas is a big fan of this album I
don't think it Stacks up to control just
yet but it might with time coming in at
number four is West Side guns 10 or
Hitler wears Hermes 10. the crazy thing
about Griselda is they release these
albums all the time and they're all very
good and then suddenly I get one album
or two from Griselda in a given year and
I'm thinking man is this the best album
that this guy's ever released that's
kind of how I feel about 10. previously
I would have said it was prey for Paris
based on all the ones that I'd heard but
I really love tan it's just got an
All-Star cast of features that is
unbelievable production is Great West
Side gun is trying different flows I
just think this one checks all the boxes
for me and I don't have the vinyl to
hold up yet but that will be coming at
number three we've got watch my moves
from Kurt vile Kurt vile's somebody that
I've become a fan of in just the last
couple years after initially not liking
his music once it clicks for you it's
just kind of inescapable he creates
these really magnetic jams that I can
play Forever it feels like you get the
classic Kurt vile songwriting all over
this and his exceptional abilities on
guitar and I don't know how to describe
this one other than very stream of
Consciousness and very comforting I
would highly recommend this to anyone
who hasn't checked it out or who doesn't
even know who Kurt vile is I mean
definitely check this album out number
two for me of the year is going to be
blue rev from always always is a
Canadian dream pop band that I've been
in love with since at least 2017 with
their last album anti-socialites on this
one their sound is a bit more washed out
and a lot of people have said it veers
into kind of shoegaze territory I'm not
much of a genre expert but whatever it
is they're doing an excellent job of it
as I would expect always is a band that
just doesn't miss for me ever and there
are some exceptional songs on here it's
hard for me to narrow down which ones I
would put on my songs of the year list
wistful lyrics and honestly uplifting
instrumentals most of the time this is
the kind of album that I can get lost in
and I hope you would too and number one
of the year I already said this in the
video I made about this album but it's
Kendrick Lamar with Miss from around the
big steppers obviously talk has died
down about this album because it came
out pretty early in the year too but man
I truly think this is one of his best
bodies at work not the best per se but
one of the best it's got to be his most
personal and he does a lot of outlandish
things on here a lot of risky things if
you want my full thoughts you can go
check out that video too but yeah I'm
still obsessed with this album as much
as I was when I first heard it and of
all the things I've listened to this
year this is the one that's been on the
rotation the most in addition to albums
of the year just like I did last year
I've got a playlist of my favorite 100
Tracks Of The Year the link should be in
the description if you're interested in
finding that and it should also be up on
Spotify and apple music
but for now let me just give you a
sampling here's just some random songs
that are on that playlist
[Music]
[Music]
flow the army of Bentley and now we move
into some new Uncharted Territory as I
go over some other media from this year
starting off with movies I know I've
done a few movie reviews for the channel
over the last couple years but to be
honest I often think of myself more as a
movie buff than a music guy it's been
tough to keep up with new releases in
the last couple years you know in the
aftermath of covet but I do what I can
and there's still a lot of movies that I
want to see that came out this year but
for now you know this is a snapshot
these are my top 10 of the Year number
10 is going to be rrr which I did review
on the channel at number nine is the
good nurse number eight is going to be
Crimes of the future number seven is
Barbarian number six is the Banshees of
inner Sharon number five is the menu
It's kind of surprising but I really
like that one number four is going to be
pearl number three the scariest movie
title to come out this year men number
two's got to be the Northman crazy movie
if you haven't seen that check it out
and of course to no surprise at all
number one for me is going to be
everything everywhere all at once I
packed a punch like nothing else did
this year and was just crazy imaginative
and fun on top of that emotion so I love
that one also one more movie I want to
throw in here as an honorable mention
because technically it released in 2021
but after Yang man this is an amazing
movie and this one would have been in my
top two or three if it did come out this
year but just wanted to throw that out
there as a recommendation for anyone who
hasn't seen it please check that one out
now I move into even more Uncharted
Territory with TV shows frankly I'm not
a big TV Watcher so there's a lot of big
shows that come out any given year that
I just don't find the time to watch I
don't know how people do it I watched a
few and this list is functionally just
the five shows that I watched this year
but this would be my top five so at
number five I'm gonna do spy family
number four is the bear number three
would be chainsaw man number two would
be Euphoria I guess if you just want to
count this season but I watched both of
them this year and number one honestly I
think it would be cyberpunk Edge Runners
but I haven't finished it yet I'm gonna
call an audible here and put in
Invincible I know that came out last
year but Dan if that wasn't the best
show I watched this year I don't know
what was last but certainly not least I
want to talk about video games I've been
playing this year I've done just a
handful of game reviews on this channel
but I'm a big gamer I'll admit it I'm
not the type of gamer who's played you
know a ton of different games in the
year I tend to find games that I love
and commit a ton of time to them and
just immerse myself in it good example
of that would be like GTA online that
game's been out for what feels like 100
years but I still have phases every year
or so where I want to hop on there and
just grind away and make millions of
dollars so with that in mind here's a
recap of some of the games I was really
enjoying this year first things first I
want to mention the Pokemon Legends
Arceus or Arceus however you pronounce
it pretty much every Pokemon game prior
to that the main Series games are all
the same formula but RCS really shook
things up it was a very welcome
departure from that typical Pokemon
formula and it's kind of funny that they
released another generation this year
with scarlet and violet which I also am
enjoying but RCS seems more polished
more thought through and honestly seems
like a better game scarlet and violet
takes the open world aspect to kind of
maximizes it but at the same time it
just lacks a lot of the Polish that RC
has had but I love both of those games
I'm a big Pokemon fan and yeah they're
really exciting entries if you're going
to play one of those I would highly
recommend Pokemon Legends RCS another
game I have to mention is fortnite
Victory Royale yeah fortnite we bout to
get down I know what you're thinking
fortnite did not come out this year and
I am not 12 years old so why am I
talking about it listen man fortnite's
great and it's back in a big way did it
ever leave I don't know I've toyed with
the idea of making a video about
fortnite for the channel just because of
how much I've gotten back into it this
year but I don't know if you guys want
that if you do maybe that's something
I'll explore but anyway I used to play
fortnite quite a bit back in the Heyday
cooled off for a few years and they've
since introduced a no build mode which
has pulled me back in if you have
friends to play with it makes for such a
great experience there's nothing quite
like getting that dub however number one
Game of the Year again to no surprise at
all it has to be Elden ring I had never
played one of the Dark Souls games I've
only ever heard about them in passing
about how they're absurdly difficult I
got a taste of that with Elden ring I
remember being stuck very early on on a
particular boss and just throwing myself
at the wall over and over and over again
and I realized you know what I should do
I should go elsewhere I should level my
guy up I should get some better
equipment and then I'll come back and I
did that and I came back into that fight
and I died immediately but this time I
did half of his health instead of a
quarter and I said you know what I think
I got this and sure enough after playing
it I don't know how many more times I
did defeat that boss and when that
happened I was in it for good Elden ring
can be an extremely rewarding experience
because of how little is explained and
how difficult things can be if you're
willing to put in the time and figure
things out it is beautiful I've honestly
never played anything quite like it I
think it might end up in like favorite
games of all time kind of list for me it
just really changed the way I look at
games well thank you everyone for
sticking around if you made it here
congratulations now you get a little
sneak peek into my life I guess this has
been an interesting year for me uh most
importantly I got engaged this year
which is crazy and I think it's been a
really good year for music and movies
and all the stuff I just kind of went
over but it's also been a difficult one
for me to keep up
channel it's been kind of hard for me to
stay motivated and I know at least part
of that is due to the fact that one of
my favorite artists of all time has
recently spiraled into this bizarre
pattern of hatred and free thinking it's
really exhausting and to suddenly not be
able to listen to one of your favorite
artists music that's taken some of the
wind out of my sails but I'm still here
I'm still doing my best to keep up with
new music and movies all the time and I
always want to to all of you who are
subscribed thank you for sticking around
it it means a lot especially in a year
where my output has not been consistent
and if you're not subscribed thanks for
clicking on this too you don't know me
anything it's been a busy year for me
and I've gained a lot of perspective and
respect for people who do things like
YouTube on a regular basis especially
when they have a full-time job and
that's what makes this so difficult for
me if I were doing this full-time it
would be much easier to keep up with the
output but you know I got a lot of other
things going on
nevertheless I'm gonna keep trying I
can't make any promises unfortunately
but you know when something really moves
me I want to come back and talk to you
guys about it and I thank you all for
sticking around and I hope that we have
a great year in 2023
[Music]